so bei allem berechtigten frust über
gecancelten osterferien oder anhaltenden
klopapier notstand im internationalen
vergleich macht unsere bundesregierung
das meiste doch relativ gut oder muss
man zugeben in diesem sinne herzlich
willkommen zu den corona idioten charts
meine damen und herren
diese woche auf platz 3 gefallen donald
trump
nach wochenlangen kleinreden hat zwar
mittlerweile die tragweite der pandemie
erkannt aber er bleibt sich natürlich
trotzdem treu sehr klar ernsthaft
welcher geistig gesunde mensch freut
sich angesichts dieser weltweiten
katastrophe über die einschaltquoten
seiner fucking pressekonferenzen new
york times
ben ali bachelor corona besiegt
vielleicht new york aber er besiegt das
bachelor finali und trotzdem sind
schramms beliebtheitswerte gerade höher
als vor corona ja seine fans sind treue
und seltsame menschen wie dieser
prediger der versucht das virus weg zu
bieten
ja ich und ich verlange dass meine
dritten zähne besser halten so weiter
geht es mit den corona idioten charts
auf platz zwei dieser woche mehr als
verdient finde ich brasiliens präsident
ball szenario der hat bis neulich über
corona hysterie gelästert jedem die hand
geschüttelt und wahrscheinlich aus
prinzip auch türklinken abgelegt sollte
ich mit corona infiziert sein muss ich
mir als ehemaliger athlet keine sorgen
machen
ich würde nichts spüren höchstens eine
kleine grippe oder ein schnippchen
ja du spürst schon seit jahren nichts
mehr knöpfchen hier wohl einer das
schüsschen nicht gehört ähnlich wie bei
jump deutet sich auch bei diesem paar
sie hätten wohl eine art umdenken in
sachen corona und das ist höchste zeit
höchste zeit denn die solche bedroht
millionen menschen in den
brasilianischen favelas wer kümmert sich
um die keine angst das ist alles längst
geregelt
die bewohner der armenviertel fürchten
sich vor einer epidemie
deshalb haben die herrschenden
drogengangs eigenmächtig eine
ausgangssperre verordnet ganz wichtig
bitte nehmen sie ihre drogen unbedingt
zu hause ja wenn die drogen gangster im
land die vernünftigen sind dann weißt du
es läuft was furchtbar schief so und
damit sind wir auch schon bei platz eins
der korona idioten charts herzlichen
glückwunsch an weißrusslands diktator
lukaschenko
naja es ist doch besser mutig zu sterben
als ängstlich zu leben es gibt hier kein
virus oder sehen sie es irgendwo herum
fliegen also ich nicht andererseits
dummheit kann man auch nicht sehen aber
sie ist ja trotzdem da tatsächlich
erfordert eine pandemie eine weltweite
pandemie natürlich internationale
zusammenarbeit solidarität sowie das
unsere europäische union gerade vorlebt
italiens ministerpräsident konnte und
acht weitere regierungschefs haben sich
von angela merkel sogenannte korona
bonds zu ostern gewünscht deutschland
weigert sich aber darüber auch nur zu
reden
immerhin stellt uschi von der leyen die
richtigen fragen wird uns dieses virus
endgültig in arm und reich spalten in
die wohlhabenden und die habenichtse in
die tugendhaften und die tunichtgute
potz blitz
ich glaube ihr redenschreiber hat einen
duden aus dem jahr 1830 gefunden im
übrigen ist europa längst den arm und
reich gespalten und wir haften längst
für die schulden von anderen ländern
über den umweg ezb ezb selbst das
arbeitgebernahe institut der deutschen
wirtschaft hier in köln spricht sich
jetzt für zeitlich begrenzte gruner
bonds aus um zu verhindern dass
irgendwelche aasgeier demnächst wieder
gegen die schwächsten eu staaten wetten
ja daran könnte der euro im worst case
sterben tatsache
trotzdem hat merkel jede diskussion
darüber verweigert neulich bei der video
konferenz der eu staatschefs per video
echt wie schluss machen über whatsapp
und auch praktisch gibt es ein großes
problem einer der früher bei solchen
konferenzen dabei war hat uns gesagt ich
will doch ganz unmittelbar sehen wie der
markt reagiert wenn die merkel nein sagt
eben man möchte doch live die tränen von
makro sehen er hat uns ist das nicht
dasselbe jeder chat verlauf in der eu
whatsapp gruppe italien so ey was ist
jetzt mit corona bonners und spanien
genau was ist jetzt mit corona bonds
angela merkel hat die gruppe verlassen
deutschland müsste dann etwas mehr
zinsen zahlen als gewohnt die von corona
besonders hart getroffenen italiener und
spanier dafür deutlich weniger
solidarität halt in einer krise die im
gegensatz zur bank krise alle trifft und
zwar diesmal unverschuldet was ist bloß
aus europa geworden wirklich wie soll
man das seinen kindern noch erklären
[Musik]
so kinder was war denn nochmal die eu
eine super sache solange der laden läuft
und man zum beispiel 60 milliarden
agrarsubventionen verteilen kann
da haben alle spaß in brüssel den jeder
kriegt was ab und was passiert wenn mal
eine richtige krise kommt sagen wir mal
so was wie corona ja dann machen alle
länder drei sekunden später die grenze
dicht und wenn italien und spanien in
einer video-konferenz schon wieder nach
kona bonds fragen heißt es aus berlin
freundlich würde aber den euro retten
wirklich nicht und wenn gleichzeitig
orban aus ungarn endgültig eine diktatur
macht was macht dann die ski genau ein
dummes gesicht ach ja und sie zeigt uns
wie händewaschen geht weil wir doof sind
europa war an sich eine schöne idee hat
leider nicht geklappt
[Musik]
endlich mal kindgerecht erklärt und
falls sie sich um diese uhrzeit gerade
fragen warum läuft die heute-show den
schon wieder so spät natürlich unter
anderem wegen einer weiteren
sondersendung zu corona und ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen geht aber ich kann
von den schlecht nicht genug kriegen
herzlich willkommen zur krone aktuell
brennpunkt extra kompakt spezial liebe
zuschauer herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren corona sondersendung in ihrem
zdf die folgenden drei corona
sondersendungen verschieben sich leider
und zwar um die länge dieser corona
sondersendungen 1
auch heute haben wir keine wirklich
neuen nachrichten zum thema krone aber
was will zu senden deswegen starten wir
jetzt wie immer mit völlig sinnlosen
live-schalten hier münchen im zentrum am
marienplatz es ist hier kaum einer
unterwegs wenn wir einmal einen blick
auf den dampf hinter uns werfen
normalerweise sind hier tausende
menschen unterwegs auf den straßen es
ist deutlich weniger los jetzt haben
alexanderplatz er hinter mir können wir
das mal ein bisschen zeigen wir sehen
hier die fußgängerzone rad fährt wieder
hinter mir an der fast menschenleere
straßen bahnen durchs bild die kamera
fängt das gerade ein ich glaube man kann
es jetzt auch ganz gut sehen das ist
wirklich sehr sehr wenig los die straße
hinter mir ist normalerweise stark
befahrenen stauen sich die autos die
menschen fahren normalerweise zur arbeit
ja vielen dank an die kollegen das ist
ja wirklich überhaupt nicht interessant
was da gerade alles nicht passiert in
deutschland wenn ihnen das gefallen hat
liebe zuschauer habe ich noch einen
weiteren optischen leckerbissen für sie
nämlich diese impressionen vom bahnhof
köln-deutz bilder die nachdenklich
machen so nächster corona sondersendung
klassiker das experteninterview kleines
problem du findest fürs fernsehen kaum
noch unverbrauchte virologen umso mehr
freue ich mich jetzt auf dr valerie
niehaus sie forscht an der fernuni
hagen.de raus wann genau rechnen sie mit
einem impfstoff
ja das haben ja glaube ich schon alle
meine kollegen mehrfach erklärt jeder
potenzielle impfstoff muss sechs etappen
durchlaufen inklusive tierversuche tests
mit freiwilligen und zulassungsverfahren
das kant hat
rechtlich noch über ein jahr dauern mehr
kann man dazu im moment schlecht nicht
sagen da steht dann vielleicht mal eine
ganz andere frage gibt es denn ein
konkretes datum wann der impfstoff
zugelassen wird
was hören sie mir doch mal zu
woher soll ich denn an datum haben das
hängt jetzt eben von interessant
irgendwann genau sind die zu ende
keine ahnung das kann doch wohl nicht
wahr sein kein wunder dass die forschung
nicht vorankommt wenn man als virologen
den ganzen tag immer nur idioten fragen
beantworten muss sie stellen sich doch
auch nicht wagen es neben den ofen beim
bäcker und fragen wann ist ein brötchen
fertig wenn ist mein brötchen fertig
bist mein puls hätte ich wenn es fertig
ist gut
eine andere frage vorsicht freundchen
wenn auch nur das wort im stoff vorkommt
in der frage breche ich das sofort ab
hier
ok kurzmann fragen durch hier habe ich
eine wann genau
frau doktor mir aus können wir mit einem
antiviralen medikament rechnen
auf wiedersehen vielen dank dr valerie
niehaus und damit ist es zeit für unsere
obligatorische schalter nach frankfurt
zu irgendeinem börsenexperten hallo
gibt's denn vielleicht mal richtig gute
nachrichten vom dax nein so viel von der
frankfurter börse liebe zuschauer corona
verändert unser aller leben für immer
nichts wird mehr so sein wie es war und
es wird eine zeit vorgegeben und eine
zeit danach und damit habe ich jetzt
wirklich alle phrasen dazu abgearbeitet
sehr schön und ich höre gerade es gibt
es sensationelle nachrichten aus hamburg
auch udo lindenberg findet sich durch
die pandemie in einer ungewohnten
situation wieder
der musiker ist nach 26 jahren aus dem
hamburger hotel atlantic ausgezogen
das ändert natürlich alles udo
lindenberg wohnt nicht mehr im hotel
atlantic da muss ich direkt mal
nachhaken und zwar bei dr valerie
niehaus frau dr
was ist ihre prognose wo könnte udo
lindenberg jetzt wohnen
bitte woher soll ich das wissen ich bin
die rollen verfluchte scheiße wenn
überhaupt stellen sie mir gefälligst
wären fragen sehr gerne was würden sie
sagen wenn ich mit einem impfstoff zu
rechnen ihr könnt mich mal am arsch
lecken
vielen dank und das war es auch schon
von uns hier im zdf geht es jetzt weiter
mit dem traumschiff mit einer corona
sondersendung viel spaß
corona aktuell brennpunkt extra kompakt
spezial über meinen arsch geigensolo war
doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]